foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much for that introduction
Hadley it is such a pleasure to be here
Max and I are really excited to be
talking to you today about machine
learning and software for machine
learning the this talk the topic is not
so much going to be about the math of
statistical modeling or new methods for
machine learning what we want to talk to
you here today about is applied machine
learning how you as a map modeling
practitioner
get on that road that road from model
development through to model deployment
as we're here together and we we you
know talk about being this road that we
we are on we think this trip down this
road is going to be better if we all go
together so we would encourage you to
you know oh have slido up on your phone
with the event code R keynote and we're
going to be
um using some polls during this talk to
for us in this room and people who are
watching from afar to be able to share
their own experiences opinions and
perspectives
so what we're going to be talking about
today is the software that we build for
machine learning
um and that is tidy models
so
um you can think of Tidy models as a
meta package that helps you install and
manage other packages that are used for
modeling and machine learning
in R these packages work together but
each have a specific Focus
they it works much the same way that the
Tidy verse does so if you have ever
typed Library tidy verse and then use
ggplot2 for data visualization d-plier
for data manipulation you can think
about tidy models as working in the same
way you type Library tidy models and
then you have access to these different
packages that have a focus purpose so
yardstick for example is a package that
is used to measure model performance
tune perhaps unsurprisingly is a package
for hyper parameter tuning so this is a
great way to think about tidy models
that it's an r package that gives you
access to all these kinds of functions
that work together
it's also right to be thinking about
tidy models as a unified framework for
modeling in R the the ecosystem for
modeling in R is is one of it one of our
like big strengths it is a reason why
people choose to use r at the same time
it really presents a challenge because
the interface to all these different
kinds of models are very heterogeneous
if you have set up a model analysis
using one kind of model the moving over
to a different type of model often
involves starting over from scratch with
your whole approach
tidy models provides a unified interface
to a vast array of modeling approaches
feature engineering approaches and
encourages good statistical practice via
its design
now some of you are sitting out there
and you're thinking wait a minute R
already had several of these in fact
that
he got there next to Julia talking right
now is one of the people who has built
one already so max what's going on why
yet another modeling framework for r
why would Max do this right so uh so I
wrote a package a while back called
carrot and it's another similar modeling
framework
um and it was in 2005 which many of you
know if you developed packages back then
were a different time there were no name
spaces in R for example and it was
lacking a lot of things we have now I
was also kind of doing it in my spare
time and it wasn't really engineered in
a way that we could sort of Port it over
to new and better interfaces and extend
it really well so you know learning more
as I've gone on about software
engineering I think if I'd known those
things back then I would have done some
things different under the hood so it's
not really something that is really
extendable at this point but maybe more
importantly it's really not something
that has a very it's not a bad interface
but it's a very 2005 interface where you
have like one function that does just
about everything and has like 30 options
to it so we were thinking about doing
more and more with carrot it would be
really difficult because you know if we
add more types of resampling or more
preprocessors or this or that then you
have a function that has like maybe a
hundred or so options which is not a
good design and so since 2005 I think
we've not only learned a lot more about
how to write a good r package where you
learned a lot more about how people
interact with our software a lot more
and then you know as time goes on you
see things are happening in ggplot even
just plier and then D plier and things
like that so I think we've learned like
as a community a lot more about what are
what are good ways of writing interfaces
the packages and then as I started to
think about that I started to think
about this in the context of modeling
and it seemed really like it would make
sense to have more of like a tidy modern
interface to modeling and so that's
really the reason to build like a whole
new sort of Stack from the beginning
from the bottom up because really what
was old
um wasn't engineered well enough to
extend and also just its whole its whole
view of the world was not really very
modern so that's why we're going to do
something different
so a lot of times we want to introduce
software and talk about let's say our
philosophy and why we do things a lot of
times we want to start off with a data
set that we can use to illustrate things
so here's a data set some of you have
seen it's Spotify data so each row in
this data frame is a track or a song we
might want to do some modeling on this
this was in a slice competition
the outcome
is the popularity column right there
that's a numeric so we want to try to
predict that with the other columns that
are in this data set
other interesting features there's an
artist feature and as you might imagine
there are quite a large number of
artists in the Spotify catalog so we
might think about ways we could deal
with that when we go to do modeling
there's a date field and we might not
want to put date directly into a model
we might be better off by deriving
features from it like an indicator for a
month or year or any seasonality or any
sort of like date based features instead
of using the original date value
and then we sort of have like this
monster of a column over here this
character and it's really like a
multiple choice type field
um sort of in a delimited format and
what we'd like to do is we think that
maybe genres are probably important to
predict popularity so we'd have to like
deal with this data somehow we'd have to
find all the genres that are in the data
figure out how to encode them into our
model Matrix or the data we hand off to
the model in a way that we could uh make
that work
and so there's this sort of like um idea
that we have of like what our modeling
script is going to look like and you
know we read books and we would see
websites and blogs and things like that
I think we're always led to believe that
there's like this perfect data set that
we're handed by our
um our Associates and uh there's like
the single call to a modeling function
it's really clean and nice and then
you're going to make predictions and
it's just like a single line and you're
fine it's no big deal but the reality is
more like this it's like a Franken
script so you know back when I used to
do modeling you know I had a lot of
scripts that I like to handle multiple
choice values that I've used across
different projects and then different
jobs and things like that so I think
this is more the reality of how most of
our modeling scripts look like and a lot
of this is about the data pre-processing
so you know at the top there like we
might use something like a technique
called effect encoding to handle the
large number of artists that requires
some statistical estimation of the
effect of each artist you might do
things like convert your you know all of
us have like lubricate commands right
that use like you know wday and all that
to make date features that we then put
in our model
there's code there to parse the multiple
choice field and then at some point we
have way too many features so we might
think about doing some feature selection
and so there's this like big script that
we have to sort of do before we get to
that actual line one line of modeling so
this is the reality of things and it's
not great I mean it's not something if
you do this for a living you want to
have to deal with every time you get a
new data set
now we'll come back to that slide we'll
also come back to this slide a couple
times and the point we want to make with
this slide is that we're doing even
before we get to the model we're doing a
lot of estimation and a lot of sort of
like quasi-modeling work so there are
things here that we're estimating from a
statistical standpoint and also to say
that when we go to predict new data we
have to apply all those same
transformations to data we might get six
months from now to make a prediction so
a good chunk of that that sort of script
on the last slide has to carry over to
your other prediction script and you
have to keep using it so it's a bit of a
mess and that's somebody who did this
for a living like this is a great
problem to solve and I think it's it's
probably pretty solvable
I really love this visualization of what
you think your script is going to look
like and how it actually ends up turning
out aligns so much with my practical
experience and that's why we want to
talk to you here about why taiy models
is designed the way it is and how it can
support more ergonomic approaches to
modeling by ergonomic what we mean here
that this is really about syntax about
how expressive you can be in the code
that you write how fluent you are um in
and how how the syntax that you write
helps you get your work done we also
want to talk about how tidy models will
make you more effective what we mean by
effective here is that it allows you as
a practical modeling practitioner to
have access to a wide swath of different
kinds of approaches that it enables you
to do many different kinds of things and
last we want to talk to you about how
tidy models keeps you safe the process
of machine learning has many pitfalls or
you know potholes in the road on the way
if you will and what tidy tidy models is
designed to help you avoid those
pitfalls those potholes so max let's
start with talking about
being more ergonomic what um how do you
think how do you think about being
ergonomic when it comes to modeling
so a lot of times I think about like
physical ergonomics like when I work in
Diagnostics we have people come in with
clinicians and they would interact with
the diagnostic machines we had and we'd
watch them and see like just as they did
their work like what were things they
did over and over again or they might
get frustrated with and and there's a
lot of that in the syntax that the way
we design Syntax for our functions but
in particular machine learning there's
like an extra layer of things that we
have to think about because there's a
high amount of cognitive load for
machine learning so when you go to do a
model for the first time or if you're
let's say taking a workshop to learn
about machine learning before you can
even get to your first model fit there's
all this stuff that we have to throw at
you we have to talk about overfitting
and data splitting and training in test
sets and there's a lot of jargon and a
lot of things it's like you do this and
then this and then this and then you
know a day or two later or maybe you're
fitting your first model and so what we
want to do is we want to simplify this
process maybe in ways you don't even see
in terms of the syntax so you know we
want to take this complexity and reduce
it down a little bit we wouldn't stop
you from like doing really sophisticated
things and having access to like the
functions in the nitty-gritty bits but
we do want to give you really good apis
that for like 80 of the work the syntax
should be pretty high level and
consumable by just about anybody
so one aspect of like machine learning
and really complicated or sophisticated
statistical models is we have to think
about what our data are and how we're
going to use them so we're going to do
our first slide of poll
so go ahead slido.com if you haven't
already in the key or the event code is
our Keynote
and so what we want to talk about is the
types of roles you would have when
you're when you're building models and
so this is multiple choice so like a and
b are the things that we probably think
about normally predictors and outcomes
but you know there are more
sophisticated methods you might use like
with case weights like frequency weights
or importance ways or survey ways in
some cases you might be modeling and you
have like stratification variables have
you ever used those things like
censoring indicators so Hannaford will
be talking about our code or our package
for survival analysis if you've ever
used that like choose this on the quiz
and then there's some old school things
like offsets for poisson data and things
like that so the point is like you know
we're normally thinking about things in
a pretty simplistic way but once we get
more and more sophisticated and the
types of models we want to fit and the
types of problems that we have it
actually gets more complex and we want
to make sure that complexity for you
doesn't get overwhelming as we work with
tiny models
so let's look at recipes for a minute so
we'll use that as an example
so what recipes areas are kind of a
combination of like the r formula method
that you see in in modeling functions
sort of combined with like a d plier
sort of approach where you're going to
be basically piping in operations that
you want to do to your data before you
get it to the model so in the first line
there we learned that we load the Tidy
models package which again loads the
core Teddy models packages plus some
tinyverse packages and when you start
modeling a lot of things we typically do
is we do an initial split of our data
into testing and training set so that
second line is just taking our data set
that's in a Spotify data frame and then
converting that to an object that has
all the indicators for you know row
seven goes in training row 10 goes in
testing and so on and so when you want
to access the training set if you look
at the right hand side of the third line
You'll see that we can run a function
called training on that split object and
that will return the data frame that
corresponds to the training set
so in that first line what we're doing
is we're starting a recipe and there's a
formula method there it says popularity
dot the left hand side says popularity
is an outcome that's its role in the
analysis and the dot means everything
else that's in that data frame besides
popularity should be by default
considered be a predictor now you can
have a lot of different roles in recipes
you can make up roles for whatever you
want but right now at this point all the
recipe does is it sort of catalogs the
data what's in the data frame is it
numeric is a date is it categorical that
sort of thing and then it assigns it
like a basic role for the analysis
so what we can do then is as we want to
do operations on our data to prepare it
for modeling we can sort of pipe in new
steps new functions that represent data
processing steps in our recipe so let's
say we're going to use a model like a
neural network or nearest neighbor model
where we have to make sure that our
predictors are all in the same units and
one common way of doing that is
centering and scaling your data so a
step function we have for that is called
Step normalize and after step normalize
you can use any sort of like d plier
selectors like you would in the d-par
select function to say which variable
should be affected by this you can use
contains and starts with or you can just
list the actual variables like unquoted
but we know from the modeling standpoint
when we make choices about these things
we're thinking about what type of role
the variable is and what its type is you
wouldn't go and try to Center and scale
like categorical data so what we've done
is we've given recipes a lot of X or D
plier selectors to let you choose the
model related context in which you want
to use variables so you see that all
nominal or I'm sorry all numeric
predictors and it's doing what you think
it's going to select anything at that
point that exists in the recipe that's
numeric and has a role of predictor so
when we think about the complexity of
how we work with and handle data you
know we're adding a lot of like bells
and whistles that are like quite literal
that will make your use of recipes in
more complicated functions go a lot
easier
so when we go back to our uh what I keep
calling the Franken script
you know we have all these things that
we wanted to do to our data before we
give it to the model and it's and it's
kind of like I said a big mass of
scripts you know parts of these scripts
have probably never been like unit
tested and things like that it's just
stuff that you've had along for the ride
for you know a few years and so we can
convert that into a recipe so in that
yellow box you see a series of steps and
they do all the things that we talked
about doing you might use the um Step
date to take the date field that's in
there convert that to new features for
like date and year and things like that
the step after that is the step that we
have that is good for parsing multiple
choice columns that are text so we get
all genres make all the indicator
variables for them which is quite a lot
but you know at the end of that you
might think you have too many variables
to put in your model so you might want
to do some sort of unsupervised feature
filter to get rid of redundant
predictors you might have like two
genres that kind of do the same thing
they're almost identical and so the step
below that step core is one that can
actually remove predictors in case there
are collinearity or their their pairwise
correlations are too high so so all
these things you can put into a single
object you can save that object you can
carry it around it's not in a bunch of
scripts it's been unit tested and has a
lot of features in it so we want to
simplify that part of the process
so the last three lines on the on the
Yellow Block we do something like we
create what's called a workflow object
and that's a situation where you want to
take a complicated pre-processor like a
recipe and bind it together to whatever
type of model that you want to use in
this case we're going to use machine
learning model called Cubist it's a like
a very sophisticated rule-based model so
in that workflow column Binding Together
my data processing recipe and I'm saying
we're going to use this with Cubist and
then there's a simple fit function we
use after that and that does all the
pre-processing all the estimation that
happens during pre-processing for this
recipe hands the dated off to Cubist it
runs all its model and it's all sitting
in in one object that you can save or
deploy spoiler alert and do your things
with and so that last like Blue Block is
that one line for predict that we we'd
like to be able to do and it does all
the same things for your new data so we
want to try to simplify this process as
much as possible I mean that recipe is
not terribly simple but it's also a very
like predictable tested reliable way to
encapsulate your pre-processing
so you know when we think about
ergonomics that's the kind of thing
we're talking about we want to do like
it's potentially very simple or
potentially very sophisticated things
with a really nice API that we think
you'll enjoy working with however there
may be our parts of the modeling
development process that maybe aren't so
ergonomic so anything you would like to
mention about that Julia yeah in in my
experience and talk and talk folks about
their modeling one of the parts of the
whole modeling analysis that has been
the least ergonomic that has involved
the most pain is the process of getting
your model off your machine you know you
you would spend time uh training tuning
developing a beautiful accurate
appropriate model and then when it's
time to um to deploy that model to put
that model into production there has
been a real lack of tools for people who
are excellent model developers to be
able to
um to be able to take that model and get
it off where it needs to go
let's um let's do another poll here
together and let's take this time to
reflect a little bit on what your
experience has been like if you if you
have deployed a model to production
think about what has been what has what
has gone well what has been the what
have been the pain points whether that's
um the the code that you needed to write
that was awkward or the collaboration
between you and software Engineers or
I.T folks in your organization if you
haven't deployed a model to production
um reflect on why that is is that
because it really isn't part of your job
like you don't need to in your
organization or is it because there have
been barriers there um there are you
maybe you didn't know how or maybe it
was difficult to collaborate within your
organization to get your model where it
needs to go
maybe some of you are sitting here and
you're like what what does that even
mean for the word production
um that's a great question because there
isn't some
industry standard definition for what
production means I like to use the the
uh definition or the idea that putting a
model into production is taking your
trained model getting it out of the
computational environment where you
trained it and putting it somewhere
where it is useful to a wider group of
people so by that definition taking a
model and putting it in a shiny app and
letting people interact to get
predictions you know we could say that's
production the industry standard these
days for model putting models into
production for model deployment is to
create restful apis so that you have you
can scale your API you can have it as a
micro service and we have this
convenient way to take a model that you
have trained and put it in a
computational environment where it's
accessible to anyone in your
organization who needs it I've been
working on a new framework for model
deployment and other ml Ops tasks called
vetiver so if you are into perfumery or
fancy candles
um like like I am um you may have seen
this word this word vetiver so vetiver
is a stabilizing ingredient in perfume
it takes the more volatile fragrances
and it stabilizes them so in this
metaphor your model is this more
volatile thing you have used different
hyper parameters you have used different
data and vetiver helps you stabilize it
so you can version it deploy it and
monitor it let's walk through that a
little a little briefly so any modeling
process starts with you collecting data
having access to some kind of data the
first thing you need to do is to
understand
clean you need to engage in the process
of exploratory data analysis there are
great Tools in Python and R for you to
approach those tasks next you want to
train your model you want to train tune
evaluate and again there are amazing
open source tools like what we are
talking about to be able to approach
those kinds of tasks
so far at this point that becomes less
true as we move around this cycle once
your model is trained you need to have a
a reliable scheme to version that model
so that you can know which version of my
model was used at over which time with
which each data once your model is
versioned you need to deploy it and
after it's deployed your job is not done
you need to also monitor your model you
need to measure regularly the
statistical the statistical
characteristics of how your model is
performing so that you can make
adjustments decide to retrain head down
that path so the the tasks on the um the
the right side of this diagram are ones
that there are great open source tools
for the tasks on the left side are ones
where that has not been true and this is
where vetiver says so vetiver is a
framework for versioning deploying and
monitoring your model
now you can probably guess from this
slide that vetiver is not just for tidy
models it supports many kinds of models
in R and vetiver is not just for R
vetiver was designed from the beginning
to have feature parity between R and
python you can use the tools that you
want to use to understand and clean your
data to train your model and then
vetiver can support these ml Ops tasks
for both Python and R if you want to
learn more about what ml Ops is and how
vetiver works with a specifically with a
python flavor I invite you to come to
the talk of my co-worker Isabelle
Zimmerman which is in the next session
about ml Ops and vetiver while you're
here though I'll just show you what this
looks like in r a little bit so um let's
say I I trained that model that Max
talked about and now it's time to deploy
it the first step is to create a
Deployable model object this collects
all the information that we need to be
able to move this model from where I
trained it over to a new computational
environment where I can make predictions
this information includes the
um the the types and number and names of
the predictors the original predictors
this includes also the packages and
package versions the specific software
that is needed to be installed over in
that other place to be able to make
predictions once we have that Deployable
model object the process of spinning up
an API is is quite ergonomic this was
our goal here so on the r side we use
the plumber package and once you have a
plumber router initialize it is
literally just one line of code to spin
up your model aware API that's ready to
make uh to to serve predictions at an
end point so this is what we mean by
ergonomic we want to let you be
expressive to let you be fluent to let
you get your job done
um in this way now let's move on to our
second point which is um how tidy models
makes you more effective Max what when
we think about this like being effective
what are some of the things that come to
mind for you
so you know uh back when I used to do
modeling for a living I feel like I was
most effective when somebody brought
some data to me
um like to know about like a new project
and I was able to give them a predicted
model back that really like met or
exceeded what they were interested in or
what they needed for the problem and not
take let's say like months to be able to
do that so for me effective is you know
being able to produce a performant model
um for you know whatever the context is
or whatever the requirements are for the
project and do that pretty efficiently
so you know what we'll talk about in a
minute are some um some sort of like
Advanced tools that we can give you to
help do that some are about performance
some are about efficiency a big part of
building a machine learning model is
model tuning which we mentioned earlier
where you have these hyper parameters
that you can't directly estimate from
the data and you need to find a way to
tune them
so another poll here have you ever tuned
a model
so for example if you have a neural
network and you want to figure out how
many hidden units or hidden layers you
should have you need to you know do some
sort of methodology to figure out what a
good what good values are for those
tuning parameters so have you never done
that yes and I don't whenever due to Dan
sort of situation maybe you did it and
it worked well or you do it all the time
and it was easy or you're a pro so we
definitely want to get feedback from you
we don't get the feedback from The Cider
polls as we do them but honestly for
this and the next one I'm kind of dying
to see what your responses are so go
ahead and let us know what you think
about that
so just as an example of some techniques
to talk about Effectiveness you know
there's a lot of things that aren't like
the Leading Edge but they're relatively
Cutting Edge and might be coming from
different parts of literature some
things we include entity models are from
the deep learning literature there's
actually some interesting things we're
doing from the computational chemistry
literature that we're using for other
types of data or any type of data some
examples of that would be feature
embedding methods and these are just
like really fancy machine learning
methods for dimensionality reduction so
umap and ISO map like multi-dimensional
scaling are pretty powerful and
interesting methods and we'd like you to
be able to use them for any data and use
them with any model so we want to enable
you to use those pretty easily the
effect encoding is the type of
methodology you might use like with the
artist field and the Spotify data where
you have a large number of values you
need to find a efficient and practical
way of doing that you know that's not a
terribly sophisticated method but if you
were doing that before you would have
had to write a bunch of like other stuff
in your script to do that before and
after modeling we'll talk about model
tuning just a little bit more Bayesian
optimization is a tool that's you know
pretty pretty common uh in the Deep
learning or neural network side but you
can use that for anything there are a
few packages in order to do that but
they're not really well integrated
overall with all the types of models we
provide you tuning methods for Bayesian
optimization that you could use for your
boosted tree or for a support Vector
machine or whatever you're going to do
and then racing is an example we'll look
at in a little bit more detail it's a
way to do like really really efficient
grid search so in Grid search you may
come up with uh for your tuning
parameters you might come up with a
number of different candidate like
values of the tuning parameters so you
might say let's try seven hidden units
and 12 Hidden units and two and so on
but you pre-defined them and the problem
with grid search sometimes is you don't
know if some of those choices you made
about the Canada parameters are any good
until you're done with all the
computations and so what racing does
it's a dynamic way of doing that is as
you start to do the model tuning it's
starting to look at the results as they
happen and look at some tuning parameter
combinations and say oh those are never
going to be the best so it does some
statistics to like estimate the
probability that something will be the
winner in this race and it lets you do
things very efficiently
so in this little animation we have here
the y-axis is 50 different model
configurations for a machine learning
model and the x-axis is a measurement of
performance and so the blue dot if you
can see it there near the top is the
current winner during each resample that
we're doing for our grid search and as
you can see a lot of these candidate
values got grayed out and were
eliminated on The Next Step so every
time it does a resample it's doing some
analysis to figure out what's good and
what's bad and it gets rid of the you
know the bad stuff and so really quickly
after like like eight or ten resamples
you're down to just a handful of models
out of 50. and in this particular case
of all the models you could have fit you
would be actually only ended up fitting
about seven percent of them and if
you're working with parallel processing
that's like almost like a three-fold
increase in efficiency so it took you a
third of the time it would have done
with regular grid search and if you
weren't using parallel processing it's a
it's a you know nine times as fast as
what you could have done with regular
grid search so these are examples of the
type of the things that we want to
implement like we're giving you apis for
them that are pretty simple let you
control a lot of things but it'll make
it easier for you to go like further and
faster with your modeling
is such a great one because it really
highlights how tidy models is extensible
the the package that provides that
infrastructure is is not a core tidy
models package but an extension package
so the the metaphor that we can think
about here together is is one of Legos
so if you have one beautiful Lego block
here we can admire it look um look how
well it's designed but the reason why
Legos are fun to play with is that you
can put them together and you can put
them together in the way that meets your
needs or fulfills your vision or is what
it is that you want to what is that you
want to build and that is how tidy
models works we showed a you know a
handful of hex stickers up before that
were some core tidy models packages but
um and said you know this is tidy models
but if we ask the question what else is
tidy models there there's a another
whole group of packages that are for
more specialized tasks I'm just going to
run through the ones on the top there
briefly text recipes is a feature
engineering extension package for text
pre-processing text feature engineering
this is one of my favorite things to
talk about and tidy models gives you
great tools to make you effective in
building text models the next one there
is the censored package which is for
survival analysis our our co-worker
Hannah is going to be giving a talk on
that in the next session if you
particularly work with survival analysis
the next one is interesting stacked
because it builds on top of the whole
tidy models framework to actually take
to take multiple different kinds of
models and stack them together or
Ensemble them so that you can you can
get a like squeeze that last bit of
performance out of your data that you
have if that's something that is
important in your particular use case
the last one up there is model time and
I want to highlight this because this
one is a package that's not built by us
who work on the Tidy models team it's
actually built by a member of our
community so this is built by Matt Dan
show who is here somewhere today and it
highlights how tidy models is extensible
not bought just by us but also by you
this is true whether you're interested
in building some open source software
for a new kind of model or a new kind of
resampling it's also true you know just
within your own organization you can
build for example a custom metric based
on your company's kpis and use that to
optimize the models that um that you are
training
now when we start talking about all
these packages
um one of the things that we start to
hear from people is a bit of discomfort
with the fact that there are so many
packages how do I know which one does
what how do I find them and we want to
acknowledge that that yeah there there
is this little bit of a um of a learning
process and it's important to have tools
in your in your tool belt to be able to
identify what functions come from what
packages however we really want to
emphasize that this modularity makes all
of our Lives better it makes our lives
better as maintainers of the packages
and it makes your lives better as users
of the package
smaller more modular packages can be
released more frequently with smaller
changes we can more quickly fix bugs so
it makes our lives quite a bit better it
makes your lives better directly not
only because we're doing a better job
maintaining but actually directly and
this is I would say most highlighted
when we are talking about model
deployment let's say we trained a model
using that racing method that Max shared
with us we don't need any of that racing
infrastructure when we go to deploy our
model in fact we don't need the tuning
infrastructure at all we need a subset
of the modeling software that is
required to make a prediction our
package is being modular allows you to
make smaller Docker images have
faster installation times being able to
have a more scalable models in
production
so so far we've talked about how we can
have a more ergonomic modeling process
we have talked about how we can make you
more effective in the models that you
build and last we want to talk about
um being safe practicing safe machine
learning so max how how does tidy models
keep us safe
so the whole idea of safety in in
modeling you might be like what do you
mean by safety or being safe it turns
out with like you know complex machine
learning models and especially complex
data it's possible for you to do
something horribly wrong and not really
know it until a really inopportune time
and I've made this confession several
times at different conferences and
things like that but you know in my
first job I had a project that was like
three quarters of the total r d budget
um you know we were doing a bunch of
sophisticated machine learning with like
a large number of predictors and we
thought we'd gotten it to a good point
and my boss came by and said how's it
look and I'm like accuracy is like you
know like 90 is like great and um and
then we got more samples in and we
missed them all and we did a lot of soul
searching in the days after that and
figured out some methodology mistakes
that we've made that others make just to
be honest with you quite often and once
we figure that out and fixed it we we
had more um more genuine estimates
performance so there are times in in
modeling where especially if you're
doing something complex
that you might accidentally fool
yourself into believing you have
something that's really good but you
have something that's actually not as
good and you won't figure that out until
we get new data and here's one of the
reasons is going back to this part of
our previous slides is you know we have
all the modeling parts and those are
pretty well understood how to validate
them and how to assess them but very
often before we get to the model we
might do something either simple or
something really complex to the data
that involves something that's not like
a deterministic like data cleaning
operation we might be doing some
statistical estimation right so remember
you're talking about the effect encoding
or measuring the redundancies between
predictors and so it's really really
important in some cases that we handle
that in the right way to make sure that
our our statistics that tell us how well
our model is doing take into account the
good and bad parts that might happen in
that part of the system
so let's think about like our Spotify
script we have all these genres maybe we
got rid of redundancy but maybe we want
to refine that uh feature set a little
bit more before we give it to our model
and let's say we want to do some like
fancy supervised feature selection
routine so we might want to pick like
the top 10 variables to give to the
model and pick those 10 because they're
the most influential for the outcome
like for popularity in this case so
that's like a feature a supervised
feature selection technique and so let's
say in our Spotify data we're going to
do a 10-fold cross-validation to
validator model and we're going to use
feature selection so actually how many
times do you think we're going to run
that feature selection are we going to
run it once
are we going to run it 10 times
we could run it 11 times or we could run
it some fractional amount of time
because it was taking so long that you
just like hash you know you slam the
Escape keys until it stopped after three
iterations
um I I want to see the results of these
uh later on today and it's not like a
trick question but there's actually more
than one of these uh could be true and
I'll talk about that in a second
so you know here's the situation we're
in is we have some data we have a list
of predictors we want to enact some sort
of feature selection routine to filter
out some of those predictors before we
give it to our model let's just say for
the for kicks we're doing ordinary least
squares with LM and so that produces
some sort of fitted model and that red
box there is basically the box that says
like what am I estimating what should I
validate here in in the way we have the
diagram here treats the feature
selection bit as if it were sort of
outside the model so if I would ask most
people like where are we modeling in
this diagram they would probably do what
we show and just circle the the actual
technical model part of the process but
in actuality what you have to do is you
have to do this and uh in this previous
slide this is what I did when I made
that that horrible mistake in my job is
I just selected the features once put
them into the model and there's a big
sort of like circular argument
methodology wise in doing that and it
gave me really bad results what we want
to do is this so the answer to this is
probably see where for every one of
those tenfold cross-validations you do
the feature section over and over again
and that may seem like excessive or it
may take a long time but at the same
time you can't measure the effect of
something that's not within your sort of
validation system if it's outside of it
it might give you bad answers so the
answer is probably B which is 10 but
let's say this model was really really
good and you liked it and compared to
all the other things that you did this
is the one you want to take to
production you want to put it in vetiver
and deploy it well actually what you
would end up doing is doing it in 11th
time because to build the final model
you have to do the feature section on
the entire data set hand that data over
to the to LM and run LM on the entire
data set so really the answer there is
either B or C but it's highlighting that
there are some pitfalls and gotchas that
is really easy for somebody like me who
studied this in graduate school and did
it for a living for a while that you
could actually make these mistakes and
and unfortunately it happens quite a bit
so you know there's quite a few papers
that talk about this and measure this
but there's one that just came out you
know we're bringing it up because their
findings were maybe like not great so
leakage in this context is data leakage
and it's really where you're using the
wrong data it may be the wrong time to
do some sort of calculation right so in
my case I was doing feature selection at
the wrong time with it with data that
maybe I shouldn't have been using and so
in this paper what they do is they look
at a lot of different Publications and
you can tell based on their method
sections what they were doing there was
a lot of situations where they're doing
like the bad methodology and entity
models what we want to do is whether
people know it or not is we sort of want
to like silently sort of give you guard
rails so if you follow the process of
Tidy models and use a tiny model syntax
it's very very very difficult to do the
wrong thing so just to give an example
of that here's another recipe we're
going to use a a recipe extension
package written by somebody in the
community called recipe selectors and
that has a recipe in it that will do
like a let's say like a random force a
variable important score or across your
predictors and then you can select the
top 10 or 15 or 30 whatever you want you
think you should do of the most
predictors and give that to let's say
your your linear regression model but we
don't really know how many we should
pick so if you look at that line there
it has an argument called tune or I'm
sorry a top P so it's like how many
predictors should I retain we give that
a value of tune and that value of tune
marks it in tidy models as being
something that we want to optimize we
want to tune that parameter and so then
we can take our new recipe that built on
our previous modify recipe put that in a
workflow with a modeling function that
says we're going to use just plain old
linear regression and we could use the
tune grid function to do like a grid
search to find a good value for how many
of those predictors that we should use
and so this is how you would do the
feature selection in tidy models now the
thing is the way we've set up resampling
and data splitting the way we're
combining our preprocessor with our
model it's nearly impossible for you to
accidentally do the wrong thing here and
inappropriately validate or estimate
things from your data okay so we're
really without really saying that we're
sort of forcing that that methodology
for users
making it hard to do the wrong thing
leads us to wanting to talk about one
more metaphor here when we're here
talking about like being on the road
being on this journey as we as we drive
down this may not be 100 resonant to
those to those of you who are visiting
here from outside the United States
maybe where you live somewhere where you
have excellent public transportation but
I have always lived somewhere where I I
rely on a car like I rely on a car to
get around and
um uh the idea of locking my keys in my
car is something that um that is kind of
terrifying because it's you know like oh
no what do I do now I'm stuck somewhere
so here together let's let's answer
another poll so um when was the last
time that you locked your keys in your
car was it pretty recently was it a long
time ago have you have you never done
this um max when was the last time you
locked your keys in your car I would
pick D about 10 years ago yeah I would
D2 it was like 10 or 15 years ago was
the last time that I locked my keys in
my car and I wouldn't be surprised if a
bunch of people here choose that they
have never locked their keys in their
car and I don't think it's because
they're that much more responsible or
good at handling Keys than we are but
rather that you're quite a bit younger
than than Max and I are
the thing is the car that I have now
it's really hard to lock my keys in my
car now my the car itself is built in
such a way that it protects against
common failure modes so this I this is
how tidy models is built it is built to
protect you against these common
pitfalls potholes that that are on your
road to um developing and deploying your
model so the idea of keys is is
um like an immediately painful problem
and uh that some problems that you run
into in machine learning are like that
um one I might uh suggest here would be
the model deployment you know you're
like oh it's I can't get it it fails
every time I try to like push it to
wherever I'm going there are other kinds
of problems though that are not obvious
until later so for the metaphor we might
use here would be not filling your car
up with gas and just driving along and
because you didn't make that choice at
The Last Exit that had gas you end up
running out of gas later
tidy models also protect you against
problems like that that you make some
decision during your modeling process
and it may not come to bite you until
you're predicting on new data
so as we come up and start to wrap up
here we want to share a thought from my
friend and co-author Dave Robinson who
started using tidy models about a year
ago and wrote a blog post reflecting on
his experience
so he said um that you know he like us
sometimes hears some resistance to the
idea of or how tidy models works that it
makes it it makes it too easy you know
people you're not like really thinking
about what it is that you're doing but
um like Dave we think this is entirely
backwards this is entirely backwards we
want to protect you as a modeling
practitioner from making
um uh silent but bad choices so that you
don't have to worry and stress about
those things and you can focus on the
scientific and statistical questions
that are the reason why you're training
a model in the first place
so max here we are
um what does this mean
well I think it means that we're at the
point of tiny models where it's mature
enough the syntax is pretty much solid
no like super major changes we're going
to be doing in a minute now that would
affect users you may have noticed a
flurry of cran submissions where we've
revved everything to 1.0 so I think the
message we want to get across to you is
you know it's ready for your day-to-day
work like if I were working in my
previous job I would be using this you
know you know to to finish projects and
do things on time
um you know it's at that point where we
really feel confident that you can use
it and depend on it in your day-to-day
work now that doesn't mean things like
yeah the unit test pass were good or it
passes you know our Command check or
something like that you know we want to
build a good system we want you to be
able to use it we want to make sure it
works but we also want you to learn it
if you've never seen it before we don't
just want you to be like you know read
the man page so you know at the very
beginning of the pandemic what we did
was we spent a lot of time like really
writing a lot of good documentation so
tinymiles.org is a website that has some
really good content on it you can see
there's section there for getting
started is a great sequence of articles
that will introduce you to tidy models
show you how to use it there's a lot of
articles about like if you want to have
an example of like Bayesian optimization
or bootstrapping to compute confidence
intervals and things like that that's
all untitiamodels.org there's quite a
lot of content there in addition to that
you may have seen the other night that
Julie and I finished writing a book on
Tidy models from O'Reilly they should be
printing them now hopefully we'll get
copies in the next week or two the
websites down there if you want to look
at the book down version
so uh so check that out it's a really
good way to like longer form
documentation to learn about type models
so we think it's not only ready for you
but we think we have lots and lots of
good materials uh publicly available for
you to learn it and interact with it
so I think the last things we want to
say are thank you thank you for being
here thank you if you're in the room
thank you if you're remote we appreciate
you coming we also want to thank our
team so we want to thank the rest of the
tiny models team Simon Hannah Emil and
Davis the vetiver team is excellent
Michael and Isabelle it's great having
people from a python background it's
really like enriching our like
perspectives on like how we do things in
R and modeling and deployment in general
and then there's a lot of other people
that have had like a really really big
impact on our work whether it's through
like helping us design software or
giving us feedback or helping us make
training materials so we have a great
great team inside of uh posit and
outside of posit see what I just did
um
the thing we really want to do also is
to really really thank all the people
who have contributed since this started
in like 2017. so we just want to like
call them out in our own sort of special
way
we don't have to wait for that so thank
you for coming thank you
Thanks Max thanks Julia we've now got
time for some questions
and uh remember go to slider if you want
to ask your questions I do not see any
questions there yet so I will make a
chit chat with Julia and Max until some
okay we're getting some questions
rolling and I'll still make a little a
little
little chitchat one one thing I forgot
to mention in my intro is that uh Max
and Julia have a book tidy modeling with
r coming out very soon with O'Reilly
unfortunately not in time to make it for
this conference but it should be out in
the very near future yes and of course
you can read it online for for free
if you have any like iTunes albums
coming out SoundCloud our SoundCloud
we'll just drop our SoundCloud
it's just yelling at our keyboards while
we do programming
okay so first question are you planning
to integrate tidy models with other data
structures like time series or arrays
for images text video
answer first and then you can go so one
of the things that is especially
applicable in in Text data is uh the
characteristic of it is that it is
really sparse and so one thing that we
have did I've already integrated is the
ability to internally within that Loop
that we talked about pass data as a
sparse Matrix to um to models that can
handle it and thus train tune more
effectively so this is something that we
definitely think about and are
interested in doing more of do you want
to add more on
survival analysis or yeah so for time
series and we mentioned Matt dincho's
work he's here and has like a whole
bunch of packages that handle that you
know a lot of times what we work on is
mostly governed about governed by like
what we think what we know about and
honestly I don't think any of us are
like expert at time series so Matt's
stuff covers all that I think really
really well
um we're doing more with survival data
will be more widely integrated with like
tune and things like that hopefully by
the end of the year we're always on the
lookout especially for recipes in terms
of like specialized things that we can
do like I'm not making any promises but
I used to work with a lot of like
spectrometry data and I don't do that
anymore but in my mind like that's the
kind of data would be great for like a
recipes package like specialized recipes
for that type of data because they have
like somewhat unique data structures and
things they do to it so I think as time
goes on you know we we want to find
packages that satisfy more Niche not
markets but you know Niche set of users
that would be like really
um you know our framework would be do a
really good job of capturing
Julia could you comment on how beautiful
Compares and contrasts with ML flow
sure I would say
more highly prioritizes model
development in having opinionated
requirements on how you develop your
model it then does some similar things
in that it provides a way for you to
deploy your model one thing that is
different about vetiver is that it is
more flexible in how you train your
model how you tune your model if you've
come from a more statistical background
you're going to be more comfortable with
using your solid statistical approaches
to training your model and then what
vetiver does is it comes in at that
point once your model is trained so I
highlight that as a main difference
between the approach of ml flow and the
approach of vetiver
and Max how how would a newcomer kind of
get started with with tidy models or
do you think this is something that's
only suitable for seasoned data
scientists so uh it's definitely I think
relevant for anybody
um you know it's it's a little bit more
verbose than things like carrot like you
might end up writing a few or more lines
of code but its Simplicity in a way is a
lot more it's a lot lower than let's say
care because you know you don't have you
know for the one thing you want to do
you don't have like 75 options to sort
through so I think it's really good for
newcomers especially if you don't have
an you know we've shown like umap and
racing and things like that we don't
want to make it seem like you can't just
like fit your LM model to the whatever
equivalent with like mt cards or
something you have that's like not
terribly complex so you know you can use
it for that you can use it it's not
necessarily like optimized for
inferential models but we have a lot of
things that you can use for that for
example like multi-level models like
hierarchical Bayesian models and mixed
models we have infrastructure for that
it's a you know this the scope of it is
a lot wider than maybe what we
demonstrated here but yeah it's it's
pretty much usable for like simple
things for newcomers and and then it
lets you do more and more as you go on
so definitely if you're new I'd start
off with like the get started part of
tinymodels.org and that'll probably do a
good job of like sort of leveling you up
there
for both of you any plans to integrate
tidy models with causal inference
with what causal and proposal inference
casual inference yeah yeah
just casual just casual this is actually
something you know of all the workshops
that we just had the two days that's the
one I would have liked have gone to the
most if I wasn't teaching one so I don't
know maybe maybe we'll learn about it
and then start I don't know what do you
think so I'd like to I was saying the
same thing at the book signing uh you
know oh what Workshop do you go to and
they say the causal interest in like are
there slides on GitHub again it's like
you know that's the the really great
thing about this job is like if we don't
you know if there's like a field that
we're not really intimately acquainted
with we can take the time and learn that
right and so like it's something I've
always want to learn more about I would
very much like to there's a lot of
methods especially on the strangely on
the machine learning side that have like
causal versions of certain models so it
definitely piques my interest but I
don't know much about it but I could
definitely see us doing that maybe not
this year but um and also you know we
have a user survey that we make about
once a year so we put things on there
and let people vote we're not really
bound to those results but it really in
the past has really Drive some of our
development so that's also a way if you
want to um suggest some things to do it
when we do the next user survey
I think that's all the time we have for
questions now if you have other
questions uh do not ask them of Max
because he is leaving to get married
you can ask him on Discord I'll check
Discord like tomorrow maybe maybe
so thanks Max thanks Julia and please
enjoy the rest of the conference
[Applause]
[Music]